we had our daring diva maybe you might
need to do earmuffs Julia Savannah's
self exit and the lesser of two evils
question mark are you doing this is your
The Bachelor presents listen to your
heart season 1 episode 4 recap grab your
glasses it's time for roses and rosy hi
everybody it's me popping in with a
quick vlog off the top to talk about
sound pops yes we had audio issues
throughout this entire episode of roses
and roses so I'm just here as a
forewarning and with my deepest
apologies
it's not easy guys I'm recording at home
and I can't hear my own audio as I go
don't you know but I want to make it up
to you and it is Cinco de Mayo and don't
we need a reason to celebrate so I'm
here now with my favorite margarita
recipe you just gonna need a couple of
things tequila a lot and st. Germain
what you do is pour your tequila over
ice okay add a splash of water then
depending on how tight you are either
eighth quarter lime or half a lime
squeeze it in there and then
little st. Germain elderflower liqueur a
little chuckle on the top and oh you've
got a cocktail everybody it's very clean
it's very delicious and of course happy
Cinco DeMayo wall now back to our
regularly scheduled programming hi
everyone i'm lauren zima how are you how
are we are we oh the ghost again every
time she's here I know you're here I see
you I acknowledge you I appreciate you
we're gonna doing a lot of discussions
about ghosts today if you want to get in
on it send me a message say hello from
the other side
[Music]
I must add I'd turn
I've been through a left-hander you can
it's not gone right nothing feels good
kids anymore I'm just kidding you guys
I'm feeling great I'm feeling excellent
I'm feeling vibrant because this was an
unbelievable episode of listen to your
heart if you now people not watching
this show tell them to watch this show
listen to your heart
we had drama we had mystery we had
intrigue let's get to it by the way how
are you guys are you doing well again
I'm feeling good I have a very cute
colored sweater situation I want to wear
it before it becomes not seasonal
anymore you know right now it's kind of
giving me springtime school vibes very
cher Horowitz in clueless you try
driving a platform but the day will come
when it will be 90 degrees outside and I
can't wear these anymore and then I have
to acknowledge the reality which is that
I haven't done an arm workout in six
weeks you know unless you count this oh
and what did you guys think of this
episode let me know in the comments
below now as much as I'm loving listen
to your heart we maybe should change the
name of the show to listen to Chris
Harrison come on in and join me because
he just came in and dropped another Bob
I'm going to put these relationships to
the ultimate test
oh yes last week it was pick a person
settle down who's your partner I only
want to see couples that are serious
about taking that next step this week is
change it up go on a date with a
different he would be because you're
gonna be going on dates but it's not
gonna be with who you think it's gonna
be and most importantly we've got I like
this Julia branded situation okay I also
turned the fire off today because you
guys were so beautifully and wonderfully
concerned about my hair and I do
appreciate it and my hair as as usual
hasn't been washed and sometimes there's
quite a lot of flammable product in it
that's why we're doing this now as much
as this show has taught us to listen to
the words but song lyrics matter
Oh picture is also still sometimes worth
a thousand words isn't it let me tell
you who's going on dates today
so as we find out who's going on a date
with you let's take a look at some faces
Jamie's going on a date with Ryan and
there's Ryan's faced all that good rudy
is going on a date with Chris
oh and Chris's boob grease face / noon
and Julia is going on a date with
Brandon hey Brandon and Julia's face
[Music]
Julia tells Sheridan she doesn't imagine
this whole day with Brandon thing
changing anything with them I don't
imagine this changing did you believe
her let me know in the comments but no
and here's my thing Julia why even say
that if you were so torn on Brandon and
share it in why give Sheridan that
reassurance I am a mixed bag of emotions
Owen for Sheridan brings up that age old
at age adage whatever he brings up that
age-old adage hope sex I mean women only
like the a-holes normally the girl goes
for about the nice guy who's Sheridan
let me clarify mature women know that
nice guys last so let's raise the
blasters robot oh cool
so they're gonna go on their date and
Sheridan's gonna go outside and he's not
gonna wear shoes
don't drink every time we saw Sheridan's
bare feet do you wear shoes outside I
usually do and I definitely don't wear
them inside to be barefoot outside and a
home you don't own that's a choice
sleeping barefoot in a hotel no thank
you especially not with the corona okay
can you get it through your feet we
don't know the information is constantly
changing now some of the people are
staying back at the mansion some of the
attractive people Natasha and travel and
Matt and Matt is doing a workout and I
just [ __ ] if anyone know what he was
lifting was that a rock boulder an
artifact of some kind had he been on an
archeological dig on the vast grounds of
the mansion what was that I don't know
if you do let me know I command out an
arm workout cuz I'm just over here
[Music]
you're doing a full arm day you know
okay yep mmm you can get the
what's this muscle JC delts and inácio
triceps right there engage your core -
oh really
Wow finally took off his shirt so
Natasha and Matt and Trebor are all
hanging out fairly naked and I didn't
mind do you know we haven't had much eye
candy on this show and I appreciate it
and I raise my glass to it and I wish
we'd had more of it frankly get it on
manager twice but the people who have
gone on the dates well these are gonna
be the quickest non date dates ever
chance of that cheers to that Rudy and
Matt go and they just talk about how
they like other people and they even
look at those other people through
binoculars I can see it so clearly oh
great and then Ryan and Jamie have the
break-up discussion they never had and
just want you to be happy
and do it under the guise of some kind
of spa date but I wrote down what are
they wearing
are those tearaway hospital gowns is
that an actual piece of rope around
their waist is this some kind of Greek
gods strong jawline cosplay I was
confused and it felt to me such a missed
opportunity because if there's one thing
you want to get at the spa when you're
treating yourself when you're
luxuriating it's a cozy delicious
high-quality elegant high thread count
so escapist opulent chic white I'm
enjoying in the quarantine it's the
opportunity to really wear a good terry
cloth roll it will give you just a touch
of a different moment than where you are
and where they were was I don't know but
it wasn't a spa no no I don't think so
now Sheridan's back at the house writing
a song for Julia and I wrote down dark
remember she told him not to worry I
don't imagine this changing
and now that she's on the date with
Brandon she's saying I mean me and
Brandon I have to pursue it it would be
doing a disservice to ourselves if we
didn't pursue it it would be wrong not
to explore it it would seem wrong not to
pursue it
I mean Savannah and Sheridan should just
go home
but obviously that means we would be
sending Savannah and Sheridan home love
it
Oh at the mansion we're on a date we
didn't know we were going to get
Sheridan and the piano and oh we're
gonna watch this whole song aren't we
he's a good guy yeah that makes sense so
share them I don't think she's coming
back
don't drink for every time he said
coming back
coming back coming back
[Music]
now Julia and Brandon are singing a song
because that's what they do here honesty
[Music]
wait a minute wait a minute did they
just say ghosts did you do this girl did
you put that in there
retro actively re-edit the song take me
back in time somehow are we in the
matrix are we in Black Mirror are you me
am i reincarnated you are you coming
back to me to tell me about my past and
my future are you changing things that
happen in the past based on what I'm
discussing in the present and ultimately
that will affect me in turn in the
future are you setting up for success
did you fail did you learn who are we
just talking to one goes to the court
[Music]
anyway um I don't actually know if
that's what they said if they said
something different let me know in the
comments below but love a ghost moment
[Music]
Julia says she's finally realised she's
into Brandon I realize I'm falling for
Brandon lol and they are making out and
oh now she knows she wants to end up
with Brandon I want to end up with
Brandon and now Brandon and Julia come
back to the mansion and I thought this
was interesting their return because
they seem to be on different pages
didn't they
Julia's like okay so we're gonna go
break up with everybody and Brandon
tells her and I quote we have to have
some conversations we have some
conversations we have to have
I want to talk to you okay not me to me
that means he's not gonna break up with
Savannah that was my hands it's gonna be
okay
but whatever Brandon's going to be doing
Julia is going into Sheridan and she
says she has no regrets I have no
regrets now Julia is breaking up with
Sheridan and doing it quite frankly in a
horrifying way right off the bat she
makes it all about her saying she's
finally figured out what she wanted I
just was able to figure out like what
babe Sharon has been waiting for you all
day while you've been off with another
guy and he told you he was 100% into you
maybe you could acknowledge his feelings
too she makes Sheridan ask her what's
going on what you think of the nine
deeper into the wound what some salt I
then dig the grave throw the person in
there and get yourself a cocktail I'm
describing a murder I'm sorry I did feel
sensitive and for me then
Sheridan asks her what she means and she
says I don't know why you're being so
mean I don't know why are you so mean
about I'm sorry I it's been a really
rough day
so mean so mean I wish you the best with
Brandon we wanted to see as clearly as
he would through ghost this we know this
relationship is dying Julia so help the
man to heaven I'm using it in these
references so don't drink every time
Julia victimizes herself
you're seriously just gonna like walk
away after Julia do at least say sorry
oh and Sheridan is leaving later guys
Oh Sheridan Shara can you get a break oh
I hope this is Sheraton in Paradise I do
I hope they find the right person Oh
Sheridan and Kendall oh that just hit me
let me know in the comments below I like
that it feels right little quirky love
hats okay so we are back with Brandon
and Savannah and their potential breakup
question [ __ ] I don't think so because
remember when Brandon and Julia arrived
back at the mansion all but he assured
her with was and I quote it's gonna be
okay
it's gonna be okay Brandon that's what
we're telling ourselves here in the
middle of an unprecedented global
pandemic so I mean don't forget that
last week he picked Julia over morning
coffee but was with Savannah by brunch
you want to do this so you want to go
home okay
now I feel he chose Julia at dinner and
Savannah's gonna be the late-night snack
okay ooh night cereal you guys me any
cereal at night I mean if you want
something reassuring that's the thing to
do it's nostalgic it's calming I can't
sleep and it certainly helps me cinnamon
toast grudge I don't know why yelling
cereal he was like fruity pebbles Trix
are for kids versus that I often turn
into an impression of Will Ferrell doing
an impression of Harry Caray wears what
I say that's something else so she still
has feelings you know Oh Brandon he did
more than I even thought he would it
just sucks when you were like so excited
to see somebody he blamed Savannah I
feel like you're like 95% in this with
me he says he has feelings for Julia
because Savannah only seems to be 95
percent dance but there's a five percent
that's mysterious that scares me
Brandon how high of a number do you want
that's a solid eh and maybe that 5% of
unsure is because you just walked
through the door from a date with
another woman oh I've got dolphins when
I was younger I believed I've been
reincarnated from a past life as a
mermaid it's true were you a mermaid
he's swimming around now come on
demerits big enough love her
don't drink for everything Brandon says
to Gaslight Savannah
he says she has an attitude I feel like
you have somewhat of an attitude or an
air about you that I'm not trying to
fight you
he says she has to work on communication
we have a lot of work but to do on
communication he calls her sweetie I
deserve so much more than you deserve
everything that you want sweetie
have that asked sweetie when we talk
like adults something about the tone oh
and then and then and then what do I
need to do in success
Brandon wants to fix it so Savannah
tells him she is done I don't want to
figure this out Rand and this is done
for me okay
she is self exiting and girl you grab
some wine on the way out because cheers
to semana but Julie doesn't know Brandon
pick Savannah so she goes to hug Brandon
I'm choosing to do this well and right
with you by the way quick sidenote once
again I was leaving she said River tears
but she wanted to love where she would
feel incomplete without the other person
and you just feel like you're just
absolutely incomplete without the other
person and I do just want to point out
that while I Stan Savannah and while I
raise my glass to Savannah and I was so
proud for herself exiting Savannah you
don't want to live like that you are
complete without the other person when
you and another complete person come
together that makes a perfect pair okay
okay so let's talk about this week's
performances performances they all get
big songs Rudy and Mack at Tennessee
whiskey I love that for them I adore
them both how much do you love Rudy and
Matt let me know in the comments below
I'm just silly question that maybe you
might need to do earmuffs Julia and we
raise a glass to Natasha the diva who
doesn't give up oh it's been a minute
since she called out Trevor but this boo
boo will say anything her and Ryan and
Brandon and Julia are all shouting at a
table and then she asks Brandon in front
of Julia if he would have stayed with
Savannah if she would have stayed and
next to Julia he says
if she had said I'm in it to win it with
you she's like I'm not going anywhere
let's do this right in front of Juliana
Tasha did this this is a damn diva move
okay now Brandon didn't do a vocal run
there he lip-synch tips so that Julia
wouldn't hear so they're all about to
perform and as much as I have an issue
with Julia's behavior several in fact
Natasha says what we're all thinking
which is that no woman not even Julia
deserves Brandon alive I hate to say
this and I don't want it to affect you
on in any level but cheers to Natasha
and her savagery she tells Julia that
Brandon picked Savannah right before her
performance I was like you know like
what would rip tonton if she said I'm
gonna stay you know and he was like I
probably would have stayed with her and
Julie it feels not good really like this
conversation it feels super you know not
good like not good not good
right before performance don't drink
every time she said performance so just
feels not good enough one it's in I
think it's dirty that she did this to
another performer array before our
performance did the performance
performance
[Music]
I wish I knew how to conduct things
why do conductors exist doesn't everyone
have the sheet music in front of them
but remember she doesn't like fake
people
and then she lies she doesn't like when
people confront her before performances
so she'll do the exact same thing to
Brandon now yeah yeah he just had a not
so enjoyable conversation with Natasha
Oh what she tells Brandon that Natasha
told her the brandon said he would pick
Savannah she asks if you would have
chosen Savannah I had the conversation
on differently and she said you
definitively said yes you would have and
Brandon says and I quote I definitely
didn't say that you lip sync'd it okay
but you know what drink every time
Brandon life I wanted to figure out what
so that his position was that we never
got to him yeah it wasn't definitive my
favorite part was when our lyricist
Brandon just lost his words he's like I
didn't know what yeah I so I wanted to I
I was if you had and then we could go
there it'll be upside down in the
different and so if you had master's
degree I so I wanted oh I've gone
squirrel Oh
any calls or baby so yeah baby I'm glad
that we're here together we're doing
this and he blames her saying she had a
breakout everything went so well today -
the little minor freakout sure I really
knew people like this actually existed
Brandon
now infuriate let me know in the
comments you're all about to witness
something very special here tonight and
then the performances happen and Rachel
and Brian are here love them Toni
Braxton is here an icon Grammer is here
baby driven sure
by the way Toni Braxton in the news so
much lately because you know she dated
Dennis Rodman he's all over that Sports
document in the Last Dancer you watching
her absolutely loved it I'm not a sports
but I do love sports I'm talking about
the emotion reports not the game with
the emotion of the driving the mental
focus
but these incredible athletes have
refined the storytelling to be
absolutely unparalleled it's just
brilliantly done the music the
interviews it's all wonderful and of
course the passion I'm bringing back my
raise
so cheers to Rudy and Matt I wrote down
I love them they kill it very sexual
good then
cheers to Jamie because she needs a
drink she's so nervous I'm feeling just
really nervous
nearly puking and crying constantly
don't drink every time she said she was
gonna puke cry that makes me want to
throw up oh okay don't feel Jamie I
really do think you're a sweetheart but
I will tell you this you have to be
aware of the emotional energy you're
outputting
it's not Travis job to pick you up off
the floor every time okay and I mean
that literally because they performed
[Music]
and the notes they're waiting weren't
great and the body language was
uncomfortable and then Jamie started her
squatting why does she do that
Oh Ryan have a solos face oh no and Andy
grammars face oh no and she's freaking
out after Oh No
oh then Chris and Bri are singing Taylor
Swift's love
and they're into it and Chris is hitting
those high notes
and I'm loving Toni Braxton's commentary
that's what I'm talking about
and Rachel's as well we were having this
conversation of how do you sing and then
show you're in love at the same time
that's how you do it right it's not
really talking but rachel is and she's
dropping bombs rachel lindsay not a
swifty I'm not even a swifty but I might
be after hearing you guys sing the song
oh but then Chris and we drop even
bigger bombs they exchanged for the
first time on stage I love yous and I
said I love you but you did it here and
I haven't told you that yet
I didn't hear it also when I said I love
you I loved it you guys know at first I
will admit it felt a little awkward I
was wondering is this forest but
afterwards backstage Chris and that
signature scarf of his they really had a
sweet moment where Chris talked about
really why they were working I met the
sweetest woman in the world and I think
that she's perfect for me and I raise my
glass to it of course it was beautiful
do you guys think that they are a good
couple together let me know in the
comments below up there in love great
where where's the jogador nurse scalpel
singing we below and by Pat Benatar now
it's Brandon and Julia and cheers to
Andy Grammer space were again sing a
thousand words Toni Braxton says what we
all could see that there was tension I
just felt that there was some tension
that's what I'm trying to say and let me
leave the stage and there's tension and
then Brandon calls our sweetie and that
is are you doing well oh I forgot even
Natasha and Ryan now they're performing
and they're giving us vocals was warming
but what do you think of these two I
will say I think they're both good
warmers I don't think they have the love
connection let me know in the comments
below but I just feel like what Natasha
you did to me today just another
performer should never do to someone
but of course Julia is melting down and
she confronts Natasha and says her
timing was rub piano room seemed to not
have great timing in this and she's
right but Natasha says that Julie makes
everything about her right now it's not
about you and she's really right she
makes things always about her guts
so hard and I just didn't know what
couple was going to go home at this
point
did you I was wondering if the show
would keep Julia and Brandon around for
the drama the final couple receiving
roses Jaime and Trevor and drink for all
the blame julia places she says Brandon
screwed up their performance I'm
certainly wondering why Brandon treated
the performance so he did and then Tasha
did bad things and then they have to
deal with what Natasha did today and
that she doesn't deserve the way she was
treated I just didn't deserve but we
have been treated do you agree
let me know in the comments below Julia
don't listen to your heart listen to
your words watch this back and learn
okay I I do know that on Instagram I
think Julia's made some apologies so you
know what can you do you got a live and
learn and then find love I just quoted a
diaper commercial anyway I love you guys
so much thank you for watching roses and
Rosie and of course you can find me on
Instagram Twitter and if you want a
personal message to the app cameo and we
will be here next week don't you know
hello from the other side
good night Siri you'll it just feels
right and your robe should be pearly
white it will help you feel chic when
nothing feels right anymore
how would cereal be and wine
[Music]
you
[Music]